[Musique]
nous sommes au latmos au laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales à guyancourt à mes côtés le
monsieur mars du latmos franchement
messin bonjour bonjour alors avant de
parler de persévérance et de cette
mission sur mars
on va parler de vous qu'est ce que vous
faites ici concrètement au latmos vous
êtes le monsieur bart sans cesse à ben
on est on est plusieurs à travailler sur
mars
donc on peut m'appeler monsieur marc
comme on pourrait appeler madame mars
certaines de mes collègues je suis
chercheur cnrs plein en planétologie
c'est à dire que je m'intéresse ou
planète en particulier leur atmosphère
leur climat et c'est vrai que ça fait
beaucoup d'années que je me concentre
sur mars essentiellement alors quel est
votre rôle ou est-ce que vous êtes
consulter à chaque fois pour pour
l'émission ça se passe comment on fait
en fait il est vrai qu on vient souvent
chercher les gens pour leurs compétences
dans certains domaines
moi ça fait j'ai eu la chance de
commencer à travailler sur des missions
d'exploration de mars devine déjà depuis
le début des années 2000 en particulier
grâce à mars express qui est une mission
européenne la première mission que
l'europe a envoyé vers mars et qui moi
m'a permis de faire mes gammes dans le
contexte de l'exploration de mars
et c'est vrai que depuis j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir enchaîner sur un
certain nombre de missions donc là
l'heure actuelle je suis sur trois
missions en même temps 3 3 missions en
parallèle j'ai cette chance de pouvoir
regarder mars de plein de plein de
manières différentes
j'ai dit que vous êtes ravi de
l'atmosphère qui en ce moment autour
autour de mars
ouais c'est travailler galvanisant il ya
on sent que ça ça ça ça crée une vraie
une vraie passion au sein du grand
public et je je je trouve que c'est une
belle manière de pouvoir partager sa
passion avec beaucoup de gens qui eux
aussi voient qu'on peut faire des choses
assez incroyables avec eux sur cette
planète et autour de cette planète
ça vous pousse vous a continué justement
ah oui mais il a priori je suis parti
que pour encore au moins une bonne
décennie de travaux dédia mars et je
sais pas j'ai pas de raison de penser
que d'ici la fin de marque ma carrière
j'ai pu j'aurais fait le tour de la
question
alors on va parler de persévérance c'est
forcément l'actualité du moment c'était
le 18 février dernier
le rover s'est posé sur sur la planète
rouge
quel regard portez vous sur ce
ce premier atterrissage c'est bien comme
ça qu'on dit alors disons que
persévérance est venue après plusieurs
rover qui se sont posés sur sur mars
donc on pourrait presque penser que
c'est de la routine pour la nasa
il faut se rendre compte que à chaque
fois la nava la nasa essaie d'élever le
niveau de difficulté de complexité pour
rendre les atterrissages encore plus
périlleux et dans le cas de persévérance
je pense qu'ils ont vraiment atteint le
summum ils ont été capables de déposer
le rover à quelques centaines de mètres
environ de la ou de penser le franc se
rendent compte du voyage qui doit être
effectué de toutes les contraintes qu'on
doit qu'on doit rencontrer avant de
pouvoir faire ce jeu ce genre de deux
réalisations et est donc cet
atterrissage a été fêtée célébrer de par
le monde des jeux étaient suivies par
des millions de personnes
parce que il ya ce côté un peu magique
que le que le spatial capable de
prodiguer aux gens est qui et qui bien
sûr se partagent au delà de toutes les
frontières
comment vous l'avez vécu justement alors
moi j'étais sur le plateau de france
info que j'étais forcément un petit peu
contrainte jeudi en plein dans l'actu
j'étais un peu quand même dans une
certaine retenue mais c'est très très
très puissant ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de soi parce qu'une forme de
libération il inquiète hui une angoisse
qui précède les derniers moments on sait
que les choses se passent malgré nous
que personne ne peut intervenir que si
ça se passe mal
personne n'aura aura la possibilité de
devenir corrigé à quelques moments que
ce soit les dernières étapes en plus par
ailleurs moi j'ai vécu deux
de lancement et deux tentatives avant
une tentative d'atterrissage avortée
avec l'europe donc je vis quand même
avec un certain passif qui me qui me
demandaient encore un peu plus inquiets
que les autres probablement est donc un
grand soulagement et puis une forme des
merveilles mans après je crois qu'on est
comme comme tout un chacun on est
émerveillé quand on se repasse le film
de tous les événements qu'il était
nécessaire de franchir toutes les étapes
c'est prodigieux sais combien d'années
de travail pour vous finalement cette
mission persévérance la démarrer en 2013
donc ça fait sept ans est temps de
travail temps plein pour un certain
nombre d'ingénieurs en particulier donc
moi j'étais là plutôt poursuivre mon
vrai travail va commencer maintenant
avec avec la science qui va être faite
grâce à cette mission
le rvr réagit bien pour l'instant
parfaitement bien il est en jeu il ya
toutes les
tous les voyants sont au vert tout les
toutes les fonctionnalités qu'il est
qu'il est censé déployer cela se
confirme on est vraiment dans cette
phase là justement où on est en train de
vérifier l'état de santé du rvr de la
tête aux pieds et tout se passe
merveilleusement bien tout va bien 100 %
écoutez le la prochaine étape ça va être
de déposer les fameuses et les couples
et les kopter donc il faut trouver
l'endroit le bon endroit pour que il a
une sorte d'héliport martien qui lui
permettra de faire quelques vols qui
seront filmés par par le par le rover et
au delà de ça très honnêtement les
instruments ont quasiment tous été
testés jusqu'à maintenant on va être
prêt pour la phase scientifique ou là où
vraiment tout là toute la collecte de
l'information scientifique va être
réalisée pendant pendant des années va
démarrer à partir du mois de mai ces
fermes hélicoptère du coup ça sera quand
alors là on le dépose
dans les quelques dizaines de jours qui
arrivent il faut choisir le bon endroit
donc ça priori on sait où on va on va le
on va le déposer
et puis normalement dans les 60 premiers
jours donc il d'ici moins d'un mois on
aura tester tester cet hélicoptère alors
le revers est pour l'instant à près du
cratère j'ai zéro c'est bien ça il est
dedans
les deux dames il est dedans mais qu'est
ce qu'ils recherchent la en ce moment
alors en fait persévérance c'est une
nouvelle étape dans la dans
l'exploration mars on va essayer de
faire avec persévérance qu'on a toujours
rêvé de faire pour marc c'est à dire
trouver potentiellement des signes que
la vie a émergé sur mars et non
seulement voici les trouver on va
essayer de les ramener sur terre pour
s'assurer qu'effectivement ce sont bien
des signes probants que la vie a émergé
à un moment donné sur sur mars ils sont
là du coup le rover et sur un cratère où
il y avait deux d'anciens lacs 1 c'est
bien ça c'est ça oui c'est un cratère
qui l'histoire assez riche assez
complexe probablement qui est
probablement deux époques un peu
distinctes ou de l'eau liquide a abondé
et est donc on espère que compte tenu
alors il faut se rendre compte que on
n'a pas joué on n'a pas choisi au hasard
évidemment on s'est appuyé sur tout un
tas d'informations qu'on avait pu
collecter depuis l'orbité grâce à des
images heures grâce à adé ce qu'on
appelle les spectromètres qui se nouent
sont capables de réveiller la
composition des roches dans lequel
de là-bas à partir desquels le cratère
est constitué et ces informations vous
ont révélé que potentiellement de l'eau
liquide pérenne et rester suffisamment
longtemps pour potentiellement envisagé
après l'idée que la vie a pu émerger
et qui dit oui forcément audi forcément
vit pas forcément pas forcément en fait
c'est ainsi une sorte de de théorèmes ou
plutôt de deux d'hypothèses que l'on
élabore à partir de notre cas connus qui
est celui de la terre où on sait que
l'émergence de la vie s'est produit à
priori au fond des océans et donc on
s'imagine que ce type de processus a pu
se produire ailleurs que sur terre sauf
qu'on en a pas encore la démonstration
donc l'eau liquide c'est une sorte de
préalables mais c'est pas suffisant il
faut d'autres choses il faut des
constituants les constituants chimiques
qui a priori sont présents sur mars et
qui a priori aussi se révèle justement à
consiste en la tenant dans la la
composition de la roche notamment aux
synthés 2 0 et justement pour analyser
cette roche ans je crois qu'il y à un
laser c'est ça vous allez travailler
dessus
alors voilà le l'un des grands une des
grandes contributions françaises aux
rovers persévérance c'est l'instrument
super cam qui est à moitié français qui
a été réalisé par un tout un consortium
de laboratoires de partenaires privés
qui ont
et je dirais déployer toute leur
expertise et leurs compétences pour
arriver à fabriquer cette caméra qui
permet dans un certain mode de
fonctionnement d'utiliser un laser qui
vient vaporiser la roche pour vraiment
regarder ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'atome qui comptent qui composent la
roche mais qu'il ya aussi d'autres
moyens pour mesurer la composition et
qu'il a intéressé plus aux molécules et
c'est grâce à cet instrument super
calmes qu'on va être capable de
l'identifier de faire un premier tri de
ce qui pourrait être éventuellement
envisager d'être ramenés sur terre
est ce que pour l'instant les images
qu'on voit sont révolutionnaires ou
est-ce qu'au contraire ou de gîtes
finalement c'est un peu ce que curiosity
sont son grand frère avait avait révélé
alors on a on a on a quand même
certaines analogies avec ce que
curiosity a pu rencontrer dans le
cratère de gueule il faut pas se le
cacher ce qu'il ya c'est que là vraiment
on approche on est dans une zone où on
va s'approcher d'une dune de couches
sédimentaires très épais ce qui est en
fait un delta d'une ancienne d'un ancien
d'un ancien écoulement donc c'est ce qui
a formé gérer l'intérieur de la du
cratère j'ai zéro et c'est vrai que on
retrouve des choses qu'on avait vus sur
sûr avec curiosity mais là il est vrai
qu'on a une nouvelle perspective on a
une sorte de viread de d'agglomérât de
deux structures et 2 et 2
de relief qui est assez atypique les
caméras sont peut-être plus puissante
aussi plus performante y en a 19 c'est
bien ça ouais alors il est extrêmement
il est sûr équipé de caméras c'est grâce
à ses caméras d'ailleurs qu'on a pu
réaliser des films aussi donc il ya
aussi cette porte est un petit peu
nouvelle pour le grand public de montrer
mars vivent quelque part c'est ces
images ces images animées ça ça change
quand même un petit peu la donne et oui
grâce à et on a des panoramas formidable
avec des résolutions absolument
dantesque que c'est à dire qu'on peut
veut passer des heures sur chaque image
qui était produite parce que on a une
telle résolution qu'on n'était pas
d'aller regarder comment tel roche à tel
endroit à plusieurs dizaines de mètres
c'est assez saisissant mars est elle une
planète habitable pour l'homme est ce
que c'est aussi un peu le rôle de
persévérance ou pas du tout alors
attention le mot habitable à aa2
connotation il ya pour la pour l'acné
des scientifiques habitable ça veut dire
que il peut elle peut avoir
potentiellement on peut potentiellement
l'avoir la vis émerger émerger la notion
plutôt grand public c'est ce que l'homme
pourrait y habiter au jour d'aujourd'hui
non l'homme ne peut pas respirer sur
mars l'homme
serait soumis à des conditions
extrêmement extrêmement difficile voilà
donc on serait obligé de déployer tout
un arsenal technologique pour permettre
à l'homme de subsister alors je ne sais
pas si il ya des signes et des adeptes
de science fiction mais qui connaissent
le film salt sur mars
on peut tenter de 2,1 vie possible par
exemple sa part être pas maître du oud
call celui qui à l'écrivain et c'est
bien informées il connaît les
contraintes d'une subsistance la surface
de mars
alors quelles sont les prochaines étapes
sur sur mars
on parle peut-être d'y aller
prochainement avec space x notamment par
le 2026 est ce que ça sera peut-être
possible
ou est ce que c'est c'est un peu trop
compliqué pour l'instant selon vous non
mais je pense que ce sont des ça ce sont
des effets d'annoncé je crois qu'il ya
quand même un jeu médiatique qui est un
petit peu malsain je trouve parce que
ils s'imaginaient envoyer des hommes sur
mars alors qu'on n'a pas à renvoyer des
hommes sur la lune depuis les années 70
et que toutes les puissances spatiales à
l'heure actuelle et essaye déjà de des
labours et les lanceurs qui nous
permettront de faire ça et on en est on
y est pas encore non ça paraît
totalement invraisemblable de s'imaginer
que l'homme qui rassure masse en 2026
mais d'ici là il y aura des choses qui
sont quand même très importante parce
qu'en fait persévérance c'est le premier
volet d'une série de missions qui
devrait nous permettre de ramener des
échantillons de mars sur terre c'est la
première fois qu'on arrivera à le faire
ça devrait se produire au début de la
décennie 2030
et là on aura en tout cas un morceau de
mars qui va nous revenir et qui
pourraient être utiles analysé dans des
laboratoires avec des moyens de mesure
absolument dantesque et qui nous
permettront éventuellement de confirmer
que de la vie a émergé sur mars un
moment donné ça sera une grande première
vraiment rendre première vraiment
vraiment oui c'est le premier morceau
d'un ou d'une autre planète
que que la terre que qui serait enfin je
dirais qu'ils auraient été alors qu'on
peut aller récupérer et qu'on aurait
ramené à vous de ça c'est une grande
première
merci à vous franck mon message on
pouvait parler un des heures avec vous
de mars malheureusement le temps de
cette émission est déjà écoulé on l'a
compris mars en tout cas encore beaucoup
de secret et vous allez tenter d'y
répondre dans les prochaines années
mais
[Musique]